>> Hello, I am Dr. Abdullah Abdhullah, the
former Foreign Minister
of Afghanistan and also a candidate for the
presidency in Afghanistan.
The issue of good education which is so important
not only as far as
eliminating poverty, but also providing a
secure environment and some
environment for the people to live.
World peace is mainly ignored by the donor
communities or sort of not
taken that serious.
What's the reason for that?
First of all, I think that because it's not
so visible sort of
contribution, and it's not that much in the
scene.
So we would like to do things which are more
visible in the scene like
bigger projects.
Any contribution in helping education, it's
an investment on the future
of our world.
I mean, it has to be taken as such.
And in such, it has to be dealt with such
importance.
And we should have a year which would be called
the year of education
for all.
And also the way to capping the [INAUDIBLE]
which millions of people
are deprived from the education anything at
all.
Illiteracy is widespread in many parts of
the world and try to tackle
the list of the problems is only dealing with
this the symptoms,
education is the key for our future well-being.